nous pourrons bientôt faire tout ça avec le vivant aussi.
Nous sommes en train d'apprendre à lire cette langue.
Voici le langage de cette orange.
Comment l'orange exécute-t-elle son code ?
Pas comme un ordinateur, avec des uns et des zéros.
Elle est sur l'arbre, et un jour :
pouf !
Ça signifie : exécution !
AATCAAG : fais une petite racine !
TCGACC : fais un petit germe !
GAC : fais des feuilles ! AGC : fais des fleurs !
Ensuite GCAA : fais des oranges !
En éditant une phrase en anglais sur un traitement de texte,
on peut naviguer d'un mot à l'autre.
En amendant une partie dans cette orange,
en utilisant CRISPR pour remplacer GCAAC par autre chose de connu,
l'orange devient un citron,
un pamplemousse
ou une mandarine.
En modifiant une seule lettre parmi mille,
vous devenez votre voisin.
Choisissez vos voisins avec prudence !
(Rires)
À ses prémisses, la technologie était très coûteuse,
comme les appels longue distance.
Mais le coût diminue plus vite que la loi de Moore par un facteur de 50%.
Hier, Veritas a annoncé le premier séquençage du génome pour 200 dollars.
On observe ces systèmes
et ils n'ont aucune importance jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent importants.
Voici une cartographie de ce dont nous parlons.
Une découverte énorme.
Il y a 23 chromosomes.
Cool.
Regardons-les avec la version télescopique mais en remplaçant le télescope
par un microscope pour zoomer
sur le chromosome du bas,
le chromosome Y.
Il est trois fois plus petit que le X, récessif et mutant.
Mais...
c'est juste un mâle.
Quand on observe tout ça,
on est au niveau d'une carte d'un pays,
une résolution de 400 paires de bases,
on zoome à 550, ensuite à 850.
Là, on commence à identifier de plus en plus de gènes.
En zoomant davantage, on obtient une carte régionale.
On peut identifier les personnes qui souffrent de leucémie,
comment elles l'ont eue et quel type de leucémie,
quelles parties ont glissé vers où.
On zoome un peu plus et on en est à Google Street View.
Voici ce qui se passe pour un patient bien déterminé qui a un cancer du côlon
à un niveau de résolution lettre par lettre.
Nous collectons en fait des informations
et générons un volume énorme de données.
C'est une des plus grandes banques de données au monde
et sa croissance dépasse notre capacité à construire des espaces pour leur stockage.
On peut créer des cartes incroyables avec ça.
Pour comprendre la peste, et pourquoi une espèce est bubonique
une autre est d'un autre type,
et une autre est encore différente.
Voici la cartographie de la peste.
Certaines sont implacablement mortelles pour l'homme, d'autres pas.
Pour approfondir, pourquoi pas comparer la peste à la tuberculose ?
Voici la différence entre la tuberculose et différentes espèces de peste.
On peut faire un travail de détective
en prenant par exemple une espèce précise du choléra
qui a touché Haïti.
On peut rechercher le pays à son origine,
la région même
et sans doute aussi le soldat qui l'a emmenée d'Afrique à Haïti.
Dézoomons.
Aller vers le plus petit n'est pas tout.
Voici une des cartes les plus cool réalisées par l'homme.
On a repris toutes les informations génétiques connues sur toutes les espèces
et on a compilé ça sur un arbre de vie qui tient sur une page.
On peut zoomer et dézoomer.
Voici ce qui est venu en premier, sa diversification, son rayonnement
et la taille de ce génome.
Tout ça sur une seule page.
C'est l'univers du vivant sur la Terre,
mis à jour et complété constamment.
Dans cette évolution de la biologie,
le changement fondamental est qu'avant, la biologie était réactive.
Les biologistes avaient des microscopes
et des loupes pour observer les animaux.
La nouvelle biologie est proactive.
On ne fait pas qu'observer, on crée aussi des choses.
C'est une révolution
car ça nous permet de réaliser des choses comme ceci.
Je suis persuadé que cette photo vous enthousiasme.
(Rires)
Cette photo nous aura demandé
quatre ans de travail et 40 millions de dollars.
(Rires)
Qu'avons-nous fait ?
On a retiré un génome complet d'une cellule,
pas un gène, pas deux gènes, mais le génome complet de la cellule,
pour construire un nouveau code génétique,
l'insérer dans une cellule
et trouver un moyen que cette cellule exécute notre code
pour développer une nouvelle espèce.
Il s'agit donc de la première forme de vie synthétique.
Que fait-on avec ça ?
Le monde de demain ne sera plus jamais pareil.
Les trois premières tendances sur le court terme
qui vont transformer le monde sont les suivantes.
Tout d'abord, il y aura une nouvelle révolution industrielle.
Au sens littéral du terme.
Tout comme la Suisse, l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne
ont changé le monde avec des engins comme ceux exposés dans le hall d'entrée,
en générant l'électricité,
tout comme le CERN est en train de transformer le monde,
avec des instruments nouveaux et notre conception de l'univers,
les formes de vie programmables vont changer le monde
car dès qu'il est possible de programmer une cellule,
tout comme on programme une puce électronique,
alors tous devient possible.
Votre puce électronique peut produire des images,
de la musique, des films,
des lettres d'amour ou des tableaux de calcul.
Tout ça est fait de zéros et de uns.
Si on peut encoder des ATCG dans les cellules,
le logiciel va créer sa propre machine.
En d'autres mots, il va se développer rapidement.
Quoi qu'il arrive,
en abandonnant votre portable à votre chevet,
vous ne vous retrouverez pas avec un milliard de portables le lendemain.
Mais avec des organismes vivants,
on parle d'échelles incroyables.
Une des choses devenues possibles est par exemple la production
de combustibles neutres au niveau de l'impact carbone,
à une échelle commercialisable dès 2025.
Nous travaillons sur ça avec Exxon.
On peut aussi remplacer les terres agricoles.
Plutôt que d'exploiter 100 hectares pour produire de l'huile ou des protéines,
on peut les produire dans des cuves
avec un rendement variant entre 10 et 100 fois celui d'un hectare.
On peut aussi y stocker l'information ou y fabriquer les vaccins pour le monde.
On pourrait même stocker toutes les informations du CERN dans ces bassins.
L'ADN offre des possibilités de stockage considérables.
Deuxième changement :
voici l'avènement de la biologie théorique.
Les facultés de sciences médicales sont un des lieux les plus conservateurs au monde.
On y enseigne l'anatomie aujourd'hui exactement comme il y a 100 ans :
« Bonjour à tous. Voici votre cadavre. »
Les écoles de médecine sont particulièrement médiocres
quand il s'agit de créer de nouveaux départements et le font rarement.
Isaac Kohane a créé un département fondé sur les données, les connaissances,
à la Harvard Medical School.
Dans un sens, la biologie commence à collecter assez de données
pour suivre les pas de la physique.
C'est-à-dire que de physique d'observation
et d'expérimentation,
elle est devenue créatrice, physique théorique.
C'est en train d'arriver en biologie
car nous avons toutes ces données médicales
et toutes ces données sur les gens :
leurs génomes, leurs viromes
et leurs microbiomes.
Plus les informations s'accumulent,
plus on peut réaliser des prédictions.
La troisième transformation est que le consommateur est touché.
Vous aussi, vous pouvez obtenir un séquençage de vos gènes.
Cela mène à la création d'entreprises comme 23andMe.
Ces entreprises comme 23andMe pourront vous offrir
de plus en plus d'informations,
sur les membres de votre famille,
sur vous, sur votre corps.
Elles proposeront de comparer des données, leur évolution dans le temps
et cela produira des bases de données massives.
D'autres domaines d'activités sont aussi affectés
de manière inattendue.
Quand on fait une publicité, le but n'est pas que le consommateur
emporte votre publicité aux toilettes pour uriner dessus.
Sauf si vous vous appelez IKEA.
Si vous déchirez cette publicité de votre magazine pour uriner dessus,
elle devient bleue si vous êtes enceinte.
(Rires)
L'annonceur vous offre un rabais sur l'achat d'un berceau.
OK ? Quand je parle d'émancipation des consommateurs,
et cela va au-delà des biotechnologies,
je pense ce que je dis.
À Synthetic Genomics, nous sommes en train de développer
des imprimantes portables
qui vous permettent de concevoir une cellule,
de l'imprimer
et d'exécuter un programme dans la cellule.
Aujourd'hui, on peut imprimer des vaccins
en temps réel quand un avion décolle
et avant qu'il atterrisse.
Cette année, on va livrer 78 de ces imprimantes.
Ce n'est plus de la biologie théorique, c'est de la biologie imprimée.
Permettez-moi d'évoquer deux tendances à long terme
qui vont arriver sur une longue période.
D'abord, nous sommes en train de modifier les espèces.
Vous avez dû en entendre parler.
On modifie des arbres, des fleurs,
du yaourt,
du fromage et tout ce que vous voulez.
Ceci entraîne une question fascinante :
comment et quand devrions-nous amender les humains ?
Nous sommes nombreux à penser : « Jamais nous ne voudrons ça ! »
Sauf si votre enfant a le gène de Huntington
et est condamné à mourir.
Sauf si vous êtes porteur du gène de la mucoviscidose
et, dans ce cas, vous souhaiterez un amendement pour vous
et aussi pour vos enfants et leurs enfants.
Il s'agit de débats complexes et ils ont lieu maintenant.
Un exemple :
un des débats en cours dans les Académies nationales
concerne notre capacité à provoquer une mutation génétique chez les moustiques
qui tuera tous les moustiques porteurs de la malaria.
Certains pensent
que l'impact sur l'environnement mérite d'agir avec précaution.
D'autres, toutefois, pensent
que cette maladie tue des millions de personnes tous les ans.
On ne peut pas nous empêcher de sauver les enfants de nos pays.
Pourquoi ce débat est-il si complexe ?
Parce qu'en lâchant ça au Brésil, ou au sud de la Floride,
les moustiques n'ont pas de frontières.
C'est une décision qui affecte le monde entier
que de libérer une mutation génétique.
Cet homme extraordinaire a reçu le Prix Nobel.
Suite à son Prix Nobel,
il s'est intéressé
à comment la vie a démarré sur cette planète
et à la probabilité de la trouver ailleurs.
Aujourd'hui, il passe son temps avec ses étudiants
en leur demandant ceci :
« Créez une vie mais sans aucun produit chimique ou instrument modernes.
Créez quelque chose qui existait il y a trois milliards d'années.
Sans lasers. Sans ceci. Sans cela. »
Il m'a donné une fiole avec ce qu'il a fabriqué il y a trois semaines.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Il a fabriqué ce qui ressemble à des bulles de savon faites de lipides.
Il a fabriqué un précurseur de l'acide ribonucléique.
Il a fait absorber ce précurseur d'ARN par une cellule
qu'il a laissée se diviser.
On pourrait ne pas être loin,
on parle de dix ou vingt ans,
du moment où nous pourrons générer la vie à partir de rien,
à partir de proto-communautés.
Deuxième tendance sur le long terme :
nous sommes en train de vivre dans l'ère numérique,
nous faisons nos premiers pas dans l'ère du génome.
La biologie, CRISPR, la biologie synthétique
et tout le reste vont se réunir dans l'ère du cerveau.
Nous arrivons à l'étape où nous pouvons régénérer la plupart de nos organes
telle la guérison de la peau ou d'un os après une brûlure ou une fracture.
Nous apprenons à régénérer nos trachées
et nos vessies.
On en a implanté chez des humains.
Tony Atala développe 32 organes différents.
Mais ceci va devenir le cœur
car c'est vous, et le reste n'est qu'une enveloppe charnelle.
Personne ne vivra au-delà de 120, 130 ou 140 ans.
Sauf si nous réglons ça.
C'est aussi le défi le plus intéressant.
C'est la nouvelle frontière, avec :
« La vie est-elle généralisée dans l'univers ? »
« D'où venons-nous ? »
entre autres.
Je conclurai avec une citation apocryphe d'Einstein.
[Il n'y a que deux façons de vivre sa vie :
faire comme si tout était un miracle ou rien n'était un miracle]
C'est votre choix.
Vous pouvez vous focaliser sur le mauvais et l'effroyable,
et il y a certes des choses effrayantes.
Mais utilisez 10 ou 20% de votre cerveau à ça,
voire 30%.
Surtout, rappelez-vous,
nous vivons dans une ère de miracle et d'émerveillement.
Nous avons la chance de vivre maintenant et d'être les témoins de tout ça.
Nous avons la change d'interagir avec des personnes comme celles
qui construisent toutes ces choses et qui sont parmi nous.
Merci à vous tous pour ce que vous faites.
(Applaudissements)